every single one of us understands what
empathy is on a personal level and
that's because we are blessed with the
ability to connect with other people
right we're born with this biological
power to connect with other folks to
step outside of ourselves and walk in
someone else's shoes to intuitively get
where that person is coming from and get
their their feelings in their point of
view for an organization having a
widespread sense of empathy is to get
every single person in that organization
to have an intuitive sense of the people
beyond their walls for the folks who buy
our products and services and who
ultimately fund our 401ks you know the
people who actually have a stake in our
success and so we can get you know not
just the people in market research or
marketing but the people in our D and
finance and HR and IT and legal
everybody at a company to have that kind
of gut sense intuition for ordinary
people what we find is that companies do
better as a result the real power of
empathy and it's something that
surprised us when we started looking at
the topic was yes empathy will allow you
to know things in your gut before the
rest of us read about it in the Wall
Street Journal and yes it'll give you
the courage of your convictions to act
on something and take a risk on
something new but the big surprise for
us was how much that sense of empathy
for the world around you gives people
something the companies struggle with
which is to give their folks a sense of
mission to give people a reason to come
into work every day and we've seen this
over and over again that when you when
you connect with the outside world you
suddenly realize that wow there's all
these people out there who are counting
on me counting on me to do the right
thing right and so you start to see your
business in a completely different way
out you know target is a great example
of this we're over the last 10 years
they have stopped competing with Walmart
to shave a half a cent off the cost of a
bottle of detergent they are actually
creating a community and they're
creating place where people love to go
hang out we've seen moms who leave their
kids at home with their husbands and
have a girls night out on a Friday night
and they go shop at Target together and
we've seen dad's out of Saturday
afternoon who you know are with their
kids and they don't
nowhere to take him and there isn't a
park nearby so they go hang out and
target
in many ways the big reset that we're
going through is kind of like back to
the future it's going back to the way
that companies used to do business but
there was a time when people bought
things that they need it right from
companies that made things that had
value right and what's happened is we've
kind of let go of that as things have
gotten more and more abstract right you
know the financial services industry is
poster child you know for this but I'm
seeing a fundamental change and it's
getting back to saying you know we need
a gut level intuition and an empathy for
people right so that we can actually
solve their problems because that's
worth paying for you know I'll give you
one example which is not in the book you
know I get called in to talk about
innovation in companies and I often say
okay well that's great well I want to
come in and talk about empathy and
they're often a little bit leery because
they're like hold on that empathy stuff
sounds very touchy-feely you know where
I p.m. or weird GE we don't talk about
that we talked about you know I want to
talk about innovation that's great and
so I have to spend a half an hour on the
phone convincing them know this is
important empathy is the key to
innovation and I remember I was giving a
talk at GE to 300 marketing managers and
we were talking about you know why
empathy matters and how it's actually
the way that you can drive growth and at
the end of the conversation as I was
leaving the building two guys came up to
me and each of them had worked at GE for
over 30 years each right so these are
people who would work GE their entire
adult life and they told me and said you
know what you're absolutely right
empathy is what we need around here we
need that gut sense we need to get back
to that and you know what that's how we
used to do business before Jack Welch
and we've just been pushing the money
around ever since so it gives me hope
for GE because it tells me there's
something deeper in the DNA there than
just following a shuttle stock price but
it also tells me that maybe we've gotten
away from that in the last few years
that we're doing things that are good
for the bottom line today this week
rather than what's good for the company
and its shareholders and its customers
over the long term
you